Oh, actually before
we take the break,
let's quickly go
around for feedback.
So maybe I should just
try to have a quick round.
AUDIENCE: Good presentation.
It was pretty.
It made me think a lot-- great
reference to the readings.
AUDIENCE: I really
like how it basically
encompassed everything we're
going through the class on.
You guys kind of
edited very personally.
AUDIENCE: I really like
how it was very personal.
I also liked how, when she
said that it covered everything
in the class, which I
think it's also important,
given that we're sharing
this class to the world,
to cover everything you said.
Yeah, it was awesome.
Yeah.
I thought we were going
to talk a little bit more
about technology and
[INAUDIBLE] specifically
because of the
week, but I mean, I
think it was more appropriate.
Like, I liked it.
AUDIENCE: I also liked the fact
that you referenced readings
from weeks far in the past.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
thought it was stellar.
You guys really ended us on a
good note, and yeah [INAUDIBLE]
did you say pun?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, stellar
like the website.
AUDIENCE: The sky, no.
Yeah, you guys were
so well-spoken,
and your questions obviously
spurred great discussions.
AUDIENCE: I have
nothing to contribute
that hasn't already been said.
Great job, guys.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: At class
night, when I first
saw the first draft,
I was very worried,
but you two have done lots of
work between then and today,
so I'm very, very pleased.
So congratulations.
And as was said before,
it was a nice to--
it was the perfect
last presentation,
because you did manage to
bring lots of threads together,
and you did get
reference the readings.
And like I would say, I wish
there was a little bit more
about the technology parts,
but, you know, 10 minutes--
I think you went beyond
10 minutes, which
means that maybe I assigned
too many readings for that one
time.
So yes, it was well done,
and also the personal parts
were well-chosen,
and appropriate,
and brought extra life
into the discussion.
And great question,
great question--
In fact, one could keep
thinking about these--
for a long time ahead.
In fact, it's a nice way to go
to the world after this class,
because I think we're
going to keep coming back
in your interaction.
And I'm going to send
you some references
on this issue of growth
mindset versus fixed mindset.
So actually in black matters we
had last week, we had actually
someone from distant
learning, Luis Aleman, who
goes with me to Haiti.
She did do two workshops
with the students
about growth mindset
versus fixed mindset,
and she had some very
interesting references
which I will share with you.
Because I think we connect--
very interesting, this
question of identity.
Who makes it for
you, and how can you
go beyond what was imposed on
you for your own self in terms
of thinking of it as an
asset versus the liability.
So well done.